Continuous integration makes sure
that the software builds and
runs successfully and
then you do the testing.
There are still steps between this
point and the software release.
Automating the release pipeline
down to the software release is
called continuous delivery.
But since some of QA
is a manual process,
you cannot run the next step
completely automatically.
You need a manual trigger in the
pipeline to deploy to the next stage,
which is usually a staging server.
For example,
testing against a real database.
You can run more automated and
manual tests on staging.
Once successful you can manually
trigger the deployment.
It's important to note that a manual
trigger does not equal a manual build
or deployment.
Build and deployment is automatic,
it's just the trigger that
starts the process is manual.
There are integrations with
communication software that allows these
manual triggers to be launched
in a more publicly visible and
convenient way than logging into
a particular software program.
For example, there are chatbots for
popular team communication
platforms like Slack and HipChat
that can be integrated with Jenkins,
CircleCI, and other CI solutions.
These chat-bots can send build test
information to a public chat room.
And react to commands
written into the chat.
That makes it easy and
fast to coordinate within the team.
If the CI build and test passes,
using chat, you can poll all involved
developers with something like,
my change is good to go.
And then issue that
command into the chat-bot.
This makes for a fast and
transparent release process.
We will not be setting up these chat
services, but see instructor notes for
more information.
>> If you have a service that handles
thousands of user transactions
every second, over dozens or hundreds
of servers, you're not going to sit
there and watch the log files
to see if it's working right.
You, as a human being, literally cannot
read thousands of messages per second
in hundreds of log files.
You can't react the difference
between an acceptable and
an unacceptable level of errors.
Without monitoring systems to be your
eyes and ears you literally do not have
the ability to notice or care about
something happening that fast.
There are a few different ways that we
can gather data about our services.
Not all of them apply to all services,
though.
One is external probing,
or sending test queries.
Some outside system will send
queries in to our system and
see if it performs as expected and
record the results.
Another is application-level metrics
that are exported by monitoring
interfaces of our serving processes.
This might include things like the
number of queries they're handling per
second or what the latency is.
Those can be pushed into
a monitoring system or
pulled into it from the server.
Another thing to monitor are stats that
are exported by our runtime environment,
for instance,
the memory profile in a Java JVM.
And then there's also information about
the computers that we're actually
running on such as the load average or
the number of disc errors.
You can actually very typically
discover that a disc is about to fail
by monitoring the number
of errors it's having.
Other sources of monitoring data can
include logs analysis, query profiling
such as Google App engines app stats,
and external analytic services.
There are also a number of data products
that a monitoring system can provide.
The one everyone knows
about is alerting.
Getting a page saying
the system is too slow.
But your monitoring system can
also provide charts and graphs for
performance analysis.
Say things like this release is 10
percent faster than the last one.
And also for capacity prediction.
For instance,
if it takes ten instances to support
1,000 transactions per second.
Then if we scale to 2,000
transactions per second,
we should expect to need
ten more instances.
Also for growth measurement.
You can plot a graph out of
your monitoring system and
see that your service is doubling
traffic every three months.
You can combine that with a capacity
prediction to get capacity needs
forecasting.
Tell you how many computers you're
going to need next quarter.
And last but not least,
your monitoring system can also provide
great metrics for debugging problems.
For instance, suppose you're trying to
diagnose why your servers are crashing.
If you notice from your monitoring
that each instance is using more and
more memory proportional to
the number of user queries,
that might indicate to look for
a memory leak.